harald schmidt die kultfigur unter den
deutschen entertainer harald schmidt ist
sozusagen der dirty harry der
unterhaltungsindustrie
er ist zynisch und direkt dafür lieben
ihn die einen und die anderen können ihn
nicht ausstehen
ihm gegenüber sitzt jetzt gleich charles
lewinsky ein mann im hintergrund und
autor von so wunderbaren serien
welten.de fascht e familie und diversen
bestsellern in buchform
die beiden haben angekündigt sie würden
unter anderem über die grenzen des
humors sprechen in unserer zeit und
überhaupt über die zukunft des
fernsehens
vielleicht kommt aber auch ganz anders
er schlägt sie haben gerade ihre letzte
von unglaublichen ich glaube 2000 late
night shows präsentiert und mir ist
aufgefallen wenn sie mit einer
sendereihe ja aufhören schreibt das
frühe tor mehr darüber als wenn ein
anderer den wichtigsten deutschen
fernsehpreis den grimme preis geht woran
liegt das
wir haben ja jahrelang so eine
symbiotische beziehung geführt dass
heute und ich also dass es war immer die
frage für mich fast wer ist gerade
parasit wer ist gerade wird und wir
haben alle phasen einer guten beziehung
durchlaufen es war liebe es war hass es
wurde geprügelt es wurde gestreichelt
und jetzt hatte ich durch durch lang
genug es durchhalten die phase erreicht
dass man im grunde schon die nachrufe zu
lebzeiten lesen konnte und das hat mir
gut gefallen was ich gelesen habe hat er
oft ein bisserl was von einem nach hof
so er wird uns fehlen ja ja ja ja sie
haben ja in der letzten sendung gesagt
sie ziehen sich jetzt ins privatleben
zurück sie müssten bloß noch nie hin
welches ja dass ich kann es mir
eigentlich vorstellen
ich kann mir fernsehen schwer ohne
harald schmidt vorstellen aber noch
schwerer harald schmidt ohne fernsehen
doch fernsehen sehr gut ohne mich und
dieser satz war alleine der pointe
geschuldet also ich nehme an da habe ich
den richtigen gastgeber
man kann auf inhalte keine rücksicht
nehmen wenn die politisch stimmt ja mit
anderen worten die zukunft empfehlen
sind doch nur einer nicht im fernsehen
aber ich betreibe ja weiter meine
studios auch als theater als
kleinkunstbühne und ich bin ich mir im
fernsehen auf aber ich mache mir jeden
tag notizen da wird vielleicht ein
bühnenprogramm daraus also von von
ruhestand in dem sinn kann keine rede
sein ich bin heute nicht mehr mit einer
täglichen fernseher vorhanden
schade wir sind hier in der sendung die
sich nicht gerade durch tagesaktualität
auszeichnet es wäre schön gewesen hier
so einen richtigen scope zu haben harald
schmidt übernimmt wetten dass oder soja
ja da wäre ich auch sagen mal wenn man
sagt die sendung ist jetzt vielleicht am
ende wenn man sie endgültig ruinieren
wollte und zwar für alle zeiten
unwiederbringlich auch mit folgeschäden
für das umliegende programm dann sollte
man mir die moderation an vertrauen ich
habe ja schon gemacht mit mit verstehen
sie spaß diesen aber nicht kaputt
sondern da sind wir ein rennen hätte da
kam mit didi hallervorden und cherno
jobatey und jetzt guido cantz aber es
für 41 samstagabend 20.15 publikum bin
ich denkbar ungeeignet
jetzt spricht man ja davon wetten dass
soll aufhören eine sendung wofür auch
der schweizer fernsehen mit dabei war
was sagen sie dazu wenn so ein ein
fernseh dinosaurier plötzlich vom
aussterben bedroht ist was verändert
sich da nichts weil das ist das wesen
der dinosaurier das wissen wir von der
dinosaurier selber das römische reich
untergegangen dass british empire ist
untergegangen
uli hoeneß ist untergegangen jetzt auch
wetten dass also dass ich freue mich
immer wenn die biologie einfach zu ihrem
recht kommt also wenn wir jetzt vom
aussterben reden noch mal zurück zu
ihrer letzten sendung ja als sie
auftraten hatten sie einen wirklichen
nicht enden wollen den begrüßungsapplaus
kann mich nicht erinnern einen so langen
gesehen zu haben und sie nahmen den mit
haben wir das sagen unbewegtem gesicht
entgegen was ging da in ihnen vor
das habe ich als doch tiefe provinz
empfunden diesen ab
das ist erklärt vielleicht auch warum
soll ich bin für 20.15 nicht geeignet ja
ich habe diese jubel und standing
ovations x-fach miterlebt aus
therapeutischen gründen sie sind fast
immer für verehrte kollegin wo man sagt
da ist der befund so oft selber den
nicht mehr
ja sagt der hat es einfach so lange auf
die bühne geschafft
da wird schon reflexartig aufgestanden
immer wenn ein lebenswerk preis
verliehen wird usw
und für mich war dass so ein kuschel
danke harald p habe ich das erlebt bei
bambi wo vorher eine redaktionskonferenz
einberufen wurde
da gab es ein thema wie verhindern wir
dass jopie spricht ja und ich ging mit
der chefredakteurin patricia riekel in
den mittelgang europäische manager
[Musik]
johannes heesters vier millionen mal den
danilo in der lustigen etwa 100 jahren
er war glaube ich 104
und als wir auf ihn zuging hörte ich
schon wie arten punkte und sagte wir
stehen hier ist mehr aufstehen und dann
breite er mit nach antwort ich sage ist
das noch das heißt ich weiß mich da
packt nach mir und sprach zehn minuten
die halle rus destinations und er endete
mit dem satz ohne versprecher doktor
buda
und das waren dann glaube ich noch vier
mal der fall
und wenn es einer verdient hat dieses
der nation dann er aber man erlebt eben
auch wirklich bei kleinen darstellern
die durch verstärkten haarausfall aus
dem geschäft gekegelt werden und da gibt
es dann auch dieses engagement ich
fürchte da schon es nahm kein ende und
bei den samstagabend shows wird das
vorher so im warmup gemacht also sagt
wenn ich sage es reicht mit dem bitte
erst richtig klatschen dass das war
eigentlich meine liebsten seien und man
die wo das publikum schwieg weil es
nicht mehr wusste wovon ich rede nicht
für 20.15 geeignet sind 1 1 late night
können sie uns erklären was der
unterschied zwischen einem late night
präsentator und einem kabarettisten der
kabarettist glaubt sozusagen an
moralische werte und die veränderbarkeit
zum positiven hin
der late night moderator sagt wir
trudeln ohne zweifel dem untergang
entgegen sind dabei aber bestens gelaunt
und stehen jeden morgen mit einer großen
lebensfreude auf ist dieser zynismus wie
viel davon ist echt und wie viel davon
ist die marke dass das hat sich ja mit
der zeit überschnitten und das
verschiebt sich aber soweit ich das für
mich selber einschätzen kann ist das
echt denn ich bin ja offen für argumente
dagegen aber wenn sie nicht sozusagen 95
prozent dessen was passiert ausblenden
ist doch eigentlich die klapsmühle nicht
weit
ich hab mal in einem interview einen
wunderschönen satz von ihnen ja ich
zitiere den immer manchmal sage ich
sogar wohin er habe behauptet ich hätte
ihn selber aufhören weil er so schön ist
sie sagten wenn einer hunger hat dann
geht der zyniker hinbringt in teller
suppe damit er seine ruhe hat der
weltverbesserer geht hin und sagt zu
essen gibt's nix aber ich kann dir
erklären warum so ist es ja was ist denn
ihre definition eines ziels wir sind
immerhin in einer sendung die
sternstunde der philosophie süßes und
deswegen ist eine der wenigen fragen die
ich zum thema philosophie in etwa
beantworten kann wenn ich es richtig mir
zusammen gelesen habe ist ja der urvater
der der könig jürgen es gewesen in der
tonne der zu alexander sagte geh mir aus
der sonne das heißt bedürfnis losigkeit
und wissen dass man in den lauf der welt
nicht eingreifen kann
es ist ein durchweg positiver begriff so
ist das glaube ich auch ursprünglich
entstanden als philosophie es wird heute
inflationär verwendet und im grunde wenn
sie wenn sie
sagen kann die oma die schnelle über die
straße gehen es ist doch schon lange rot
dann heißt es das ist zynisch und
menschenverachtend immer in dieser
kombination
ja ich glaube dass die meisten nicht
wissen was zynismus ist und deshalb
einfach so wenn wenn wenn sie was finden
oder ohne zynisch jetzt im rheinland
dann natürlich auch in der sprachlichen
kombination zynisch und
menschenverachtend
man hat ihnen ja auch oft man mal wieder
dass das etikett menschenverachtend
angeklebt ich erinnere mich jetzt gab
mal eine zeit der polen witze nachdem
sich die leute darüber aufgeregt hatten
konnten sie natürlich nicht aufhören in
jeder sendung einen polen witz zu
erzählen
wie fühlt man sich wenn man da in seiner
ecke geschubst wird und dass das hat
mich ehrlich gesagt zum teil überrascht
hat mich nicht weiter belastet dass
bezüglich glaube ich hauptsächlich
darauf dass viele der autos ist 15 jahre
her die wirtschaftliche situation hat
sich so verändert deswegen habe ich
hauptsächlich aufgehört als die witze
nie mehr stimmten
dass die autos eben nach polen gingen
wenn sie geklaut wurden deswegen stand
ja auch bei autovermietern fahrten in
länder des ehemaligen ostblocks nicht
erlaubt daraufhin wurde ich zum
polnischen botschafter zum kaffee
eingeladen
und der sagte mir
sehr diplomatisch jetzt reicht's ich
denke wir auch bände mit polnischen
satirikern und so weiter und ich habe
gesagt wir haben verstanden aber da hat
es sich das thema schon längst es wurde
ich hab ich noch immer über die polen
wird sie geredet da gab es schon lange
nicht mehr weil ich habe gelesen dass
polen ein wirtschaftswachstum von 15%
hatte zu der zeit und damit war die die
die nummer autoklau und farah diba
hinfällig sie sagten gerade es wurde
immer noch über die polen wird zugeredet
ist das nicht überhaupt ein problem dass
einem die leute immer auf dinge
ansprechen die man schon seit langer
zeit nicht mehr macht damals and
miteinander tolle sketche und das finde
ich großartig weil und das sage ich
gerne hier in zürich für das land dem
man früher kaffee geschäfte man ging im
keller schneiden zum kupon bei der bank
mann hatte irgendwann was solide
angelegt und lebte noch jahrelang davon
das ist eine erfahrung die ich jetzt
mache wenn man so lange im fernsehen war
spielt es für das publikum keine rolle
ob man noch im fernsehen ist es sprechen
mich leute auf einer rolltreppe am
flughafen an wenn totaler fan von ihnen
da das war der hammer wie sie damals dem
feuerstein als bettvorleger gezogen
haben das ist 20 jahre her
ja so wie ja auch viele unserer unsere
zdf zuschauer immer noch einen schönen
römern film warten der neuen natürlich
also das ist wenn man sagen halt drei
bis vier sketche hat die sich ein gehabt
haben
das war bei hape kerkeling die falsche
beatrix das war bei loriot unter anderem
natürlich früher war mehr lametta hat
die nudel so dann reicht das im grunde
für ein behagliches leben am fuße von
eiger mönch und jungfrau herzlichen in
diesem punkt nachfüllen bei mir wird
wahrscheinlich auch förster familie auf
meinem grabstein stehen weil das halt
mal so naja gleiche sendung war das
bleibt einem danke aber ärgert es sie
nicht in die leute sagen der darf sich
auch gar nicht mehr verändern weil wir
wollen ihnen zu haben wie er immer war
das ist das ist wirklich das muss man
akzeptieren das ist der beruf das ist so
wie klaus irgendwo so einfach professor
brinkmann war und ostrava
derrick und das ist ja schon ein großer
glücksfall wenn schauspieler auf so ne
rolle trifft und dann sein leben damit
bestreiten kann ja das ist ja der irrtum
es gibt ja nur ganz ganz ganz wenig
schauspieler die wirklich wandlungsfähig
sind die meisten glauben wenn sich eine
andere bad kleben oder was dann wäre es
ja auch eine andere figur ja professor
brinkmann derrick war war immer der weg
auch wenn der weg aufs traumschiff ging
oder oder sonst wohin es war immer der
ich hatte war ihm bei den herren länder
chance mehr den eindruck dass da ein
spieler eine rolle gefunden hat das war
ein bisschen wie sowie bei letterman
oder bei lenovo man eigentlich keinen
unterschied zwischen zwischen man hat
das gefühl der kann privat gar nicht
anders sein als er da ist der spielt das
nicht so das war das doch eine rolle
nein es ist die haltung ob es ist man
hat diese haltung ist diese novelle und
auf der surft man ja es gibt ja leute
die eine late night show versuchen aber
dann anfangen die rolle zu spielen und
das funktioniert nicht weil wenn sie
sozusagen anfangen das opfer mal aus
einer anderen perspektive zu sehen
dann können sie in den sozial
therapeutischen bereich gehen oder sie
können den bundespräsidenten auf reisen
begleiten oder wann aber eine
late-night-show können sie dann
definitiv nicht moderieren also wer die
falschen schnürsenkel hat ist fällig
also ein gewisser der zionismus muss
original sein so funktioniert's nicht
auf der lauer
für mich ist zynismus keine negative
eigenschaft aber entdeckt man das so
allmählich an sich oder war das von
anfang an von der ersten late-night-show
man da oder merck wächst man da so
langsam rein und verschreibt sich weil
es doch das war schon vom gymnasium an
da ja
eine mitschülerin eben im
geschichtsunterricht gefragt hat mit mir
im büro bisher kenne dann wurde darüber
gelacht und dann hat man nicht gesagt
was auf die französische revolution ist
ein zentrales geschichtliches ereignis
gewesen
und da war ob es wäre ein ganz
entscheidender wohltäter
das ist klar dass das prüfungsstoff sein
kann sondern dann würde einfach dann 50
mal in dieser stunde gefragt müssen wir
bis birken und es wurde auf einem
schulausflug gefragt und es wurde auf
der fahrt im schulbus durch nico gesagt
eine durchsage mit allen rubriken was
aber sind das war dann niemand wo visp
erkannte der übrigens auf einem solchen
tisch verblutet ist mit vermarkter dem
unterkiefer über stunden hin
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass sie
in der schule der klassenclown waren das
ist eigentlich nicht ihre art ist humor
als oder waren sie da ich war schon klar
ja ich war ja noch nicht sicher ist
sozusagen das sagen wir mal ab der
mittelstufe war eine permanente
vorbereitungszeit für die
aufnahmeprüfung an der schauspielschule
ich wusste ja nicht ob ich schaffe ich
kam mir aus einem vollkommen theater
ferne milieu und das war
permanentes training lachen die leute
und wenn man dann an die
schauspielschule geht neue auch sehr
viele mitschüler dann mit einem hoch
intellektuellen anspruch da sind man
kommt so aus dieser wie bringe ich die
leute zum lachen perspektive ist es dann
nicht so ein kulturschock der erst mal
es war für mich ein totaler außen ich
war in gewisser weise ein außenseiter
weil der rest auf der schauspielschule
saß eigentlich heulend vor der wand
schlug mit der stirn dagegen und sagte
so in zehn minuten abstand schmerz die
große genesis ja und ich kann wieder
dabei und es gab noch im zweiten der in
so draufhat wenig das war ulrich tukur
wo ich immer in die knie gehen wenn ich
irgendwo in europa städte mit mit
plakaten von ihnen gepflastert
die karriere von tuck uhr begann der
jahrgang unter ihm spielte die
geschwister von klausmann und tukur
musste als jüngerer die karten abreißen
beim eingang und regisseur verhoeven kam
um sich die vier anzugucken weil sucht
eine besetzung und sagte wer ist der typ
der den preis und das war to kur und so
ging die karriere los dann am dienstag
für petto und da war natürlich alle ein
bisschen irritiert weil man konnte
darauf wetten
fünf minuten nach unterrichtsbeginn kam
trug mit einem akkordeon um die ecke und
sang hans albers oder sowas
also ich war ja immer schon pulver oder
oder showmaster und der terrestar kleben
ja in nächster woche vor sprechen aber
ich bin ich mache ist nachgerade luise
kabale und liebe aber ich ich ich ich
ich spüre es noch nicht so
und während ich einfach zehn rollen
parat hatte und auf knopfdruck und man
warf mir dann ein extremes gefälligkeits
bewusstsein vor das schlimmste für einen
heutigen schauspielschüler da müsste ich
arbeiten sonst sonst wäre der beruf
nicht kompatibel es hat ja auch als
schauspieler in dem sich nicht
funktioniert aber ich habe dann relativ
schnell über die kantine düsseldorfer
kom m ödchen gefunden aber dass das
damals war man auf dem spiel nimmt er
jedes wort wahnsinnig ernst was angesagt
also sich um die sachen gemacht den
jemanden gefallen außer den zuschauern
zumindest später wurde der kreis der
zuschauer auch überschaubar aber das ist
eben der lauf der zeit
mir ist aufgefallen wenn man so ein
querschnitt durch late night show man
sieht keinen unterschied aus der zeit wo
der millionen zuschauten aus verzeigt
worden schluss fand ich glaube ich noch
5000 bei sky an guten abenden einen
guten abend
man hat das gefühl ihnen war es höflich
ausgedrückt egal ja sehr höflich
ausgedrückt weil ich ja immer die
gleiche situation erlebt habe
ging ja jeden abend in mein studio ein
das über 19 jahre und 400 sender
identisch war
die seine hand habe das bühnenbild
geschenk zum abschied
und dann haben wir ein vierter neuen
sender und zwei grüne striche
reingemacht oder in der lampe mehr
aber ich wenn diese studio hier mal von
schweizer fernsehen mal von rtl mal von
der mikro bezahlt würde würde das ja für
die gäste die hier sitzen keinen
unterschied machen der tisch und die
atmosphäre bleibt dieselbe
und insofern habe ich das ich kann nur
immer natürlich die die verzweifelte
gesichter teilweise wenn ich morgens
reinkam als es noch die quote gab und
dann halt wenn sie dann so abends
gefragt und der kneipe was machen der
schnitt jetzt wollte ich sowieso wurde
am 3 mal da machen wir ja ich hab kein
sky und so waren dann auch natürlich
teilweise sehr wenig zuschauer im studio
teilweise waren 40 zuschauer drin die
über eine agentur bezahlt wurden um zum
see hinein zu sein und der
gesichtsausdruck war wirklich ich mache
es dezent also ab mittags eine gameshow
am späten nachmittag eine gerichtsshow
meine mutter ist mein onkel oder soja
und abends ich das war es war teilweise
gruselig aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
hab sehr genossen
er will mich jemand dafür bezahlt harald
schmidt wechselt sofort mein beruf ja
das ist sehr sehr liebenswürdig von
ihnen aber das ist schon das sind
menschen die
wirklich damit gar nichts anfangen kann
ich aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
harald schmidt präsentiert in einem
leeren studio ohne zuschauer vor ort
kann ich es mir nicht vorstellen
es war insofern 50 leute da wir haben
links und rechts die die plätze schwer
mit schwarzen tüchern abgehängt
damit das nicht so aussieht wenn die
kamera schwenkt übrigens ein durchaus
gebräuchliche usus in der fernsehwelt
nur außer mir gibt keiner zu und also
zum beispiel bei weil sein wie die heute
show zeigt vorher bevor es losgeht
ausschnitte aus pleiten pech und pannen
wo einfach zwei jährige die treppe
runter geschützt werden
und da wird es gefilmt und lacht das
publikum weg und diese ausschnitte
werden dann geschnitten nach einer
angeblichen plante innerhalb der sendung
also das voll verachtet des zuschauers
aber der zuschauer mag das der sichere
liter
und insofern ist es auch völlig okay
aber das ging gegen beim berufsethos ja
also ich war immer keine rein
geschnittene lacher niemals ich habe
auch verboten an zu klatschen ja ich
habe teilweise zehnminütiges tandabs
gemacht ohne eine reaktion man muss
vielleicht das wort an klatschen für den
laien zuschauer eingelassen ist so der
der auf lohnsteuerkarte arbeitende
wdr-redakteur sitzt drinnen und ich sage
also angela merkel als bundeskanzlerin
dann hat das publikum was gekauft wurde
und sie hören es immer weil sie haben
immer diese ja und ich habe es ja es
wird nicht an geklatscht denn das ist
wahrscheinlich ist es eine form von von
sado masochismus eine wirklich gute
pointe auch zu haben die in schweigen
ändert ja das ist ja das muss man ja aus
halten ja aber da fing für mich der job
an weil mit dem höchst irdischen
publikum kann es jeder
sie waren in allen bereichen beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen beim privaten
beim petit wieder wo sind da die
unterschiede gibt es da grundsätzliche
unterschiede oder ist das alles dasselbe
also dass das
dass das öffentlich rechtliche fernsehen
in deutschland kann ich ein so
beschreiben was die unterhaltung angeht
originalton wir hätten gerne dieter
bohlen aber ohne dieter bohlen ja das
private fernsehen lebt eigentlich davon
wie die werbezeiten verkauft werden und
wie in 84 nebengeschäften von
kaffeetasse bis pay per view bis
paperless repair nun weiß nicht was das
geld reinkommt und die seriöseste
situation ist beim pay-tv weil dort
heißt es ja und das ist schade
die leben von den abonnenten da wird
überhaupt nicht drumrum gerechnet dass
wahlgeräte das war eine sehr seriöse
arbeitsweise war für mich eigentlich
dass ein spannendes die die verzweifelte
situation ist öffentlich rechtlich weil
die haben sieben milliarden gebühren wir
müssen auf gar keine quote auf gar
nichts gucken und dort herrscht
eigentlich die größte angst und
unsicherheit aber eine situation die
nicht nur für deutschland gilt sondern
alle für alle länder die öffentlich
rechtliche sender haben sie müssten
nicht auf die quote gucken aber sie
kommen ganz gewaltig sie guckt nur auf
warum das hat sich so eingebürgert dass
sven wenn sie aussagen
hast du den dreck gestern angesehen sagt
in der redakteur 16 prozent was bedeutet
aber 16 prozent und das ist toll
ja und das bestreitet auch gar keiner
und es ist halt dieser dieser jetlag von
fünf bis sieben jahren
also wir wollen boden holen ohne bohlen
ja und wahrscheinlich kommt auch bald
dieses format polen ohne bohlen
also ich habe gerade gehört dass das zdf
geschlossen hat sie müssten jetzt
breaking bad auch produzent ja eine
sendung überhaupt nicht ins zdf pass ist
das der versuch einfach denn alle sender
machen junges publikum ganz egal was es
kostet also soweit ich das wirklich gab
es spielt ja der von mir wirklich sehr
sehr sehr verehrte bastian pastewka
ganz großer ist ja also das ist ein
einmal feuerwerk
es spielt diese hauptrolle ich habe
breaking bad nie gesehen gehöre zu den
leuten die die 34 amerikanische serie
namen kennen und sagen warum schaffen
wir das in deutschland ja es gibt noch
so ein paar aber ich habe es nie gesehen
ich gucke auch nicht ich rede auch
enthusiastisch und mit atemnot über
house of cards und kevin spacey
obwohl ich nur drei folgen gesehen habe
aber da gehöre ich schon zu denen die
viel gesehen haben ich weiß es nicht
warum will das öffentlich rechtliche
fernsehen junge zuschauer wollen der
durchschnittszuschauer bei der sendung
mit der maus ist 56 ja der
durchschnittsdeutsche ist 45
die deutschen werden auf wunsch retzlaff
der götter im schnitt 192 mittlerweile
durch medizin und rente mit 63 wenn es
etwas gibt wenn es jemanden gibt der
sich nicht für fernsehen interessiert
sind ist die jungen zuschauer
die sind dies die haben die handys als
ob's körperteile wären ja die dtg zeigen
sich maximal noch 130 clips das gilt so
hast du das gesehen
oder sie gehen ins kino oder sie gucken
auf dvd oder sie gucken ob elias
irgendwo um die ecke persönlich springt
aber der versuch sie wenn wir eine
62-jährige fernsehdirektorin gegenüber
sitzt ja wo ich sage kaum noch von der
handtasche zu unterscheiden und wie man
sagt wir müssen klare verwerten
das sei mein liebes kind wann warst du
zum letzten mal beim einfachen volk auf
der straße die die wissen noch dass es
ard und zdf gibt weil es fußball gibt
übrigens vier milliarden summen ohne
dass refinanzieren zu müssen
aber ansonsten sind die längst auf
irgendwelchen kanälen oder überhaupt mit
komplett eigenen programm im internet
heißt dass das fernsehen nehmen ihren
augen eine sache jetzt mal diskret eine
aussterbende kunstform es nein denn
deswegen sind wir in einer sternstunde
der philosophie denn pro woche
ende gucken 30 40 millionen deutsche
fernsehen unter anderem mit dass geistig
nachvollziehbare beste was es gibt den
tatort hörer täglich mord gegen solchen
haus vor allen dingen mit wirklich dem
dümmsten also es gibt ja um 21 uhr 20
kräften kind eine maschinenpistole an
die schläfe gehalten im
montessori-kindergarten ja neben mir auf
der couch höre ich wie menschen sagen
hey beruhige dich beruhige dich es ist
für die ganz blöden wird noch mal
spannung erzeugt um 21.20 wird im
deutschen fernsehen kein kind mehr
erschossen und so kommt ja auch wert wer
wird erschossen zurecht finde ich
übrigens der verhaltensauffällige
patchwork vater da frage ich allerdings
gibt es keinen dramaturgen der sagt dann
erschießen wir gleich am anfang und er
wird gespielt von til schweiger noch mal
alle was davon
aber das gehört ja zu dieser runde dass
man widersprüchlich mit sich selber
spricht es gibt ja so interne regeln
beim krimi
der täter ist immer der schauspieler mit
der hübschen garage kann man ja immer
nachrechnen da braucht man auch gucken
aber warum in deutschland ist ja im
moment jeden abend krimi team auf in
einem sender läuft immer ein krimi ja
woher diese warum wird das plötzlich zum
wichtigsten sender bestandteil ich war
noch ein sein ich würde sagen
aggressions abfuhr
schauen sie wir leben in einer zeit in
der selbst größter gesprächsbereit ist
ja die soldaten gehen in elternzeit
die mütter nehmen still urlaub auch in
front wir haben 70 jahre in
zentraleuropa keinen krieg mehr glaube
ich kann man sagen ja irgendwo muss die
aggression ja hin
darum der täglicher mord im fernsehen
ich könnte es mir vorstellen so
wo sonst es ist ja es gibt noch gewisse
aggressions ausbrüche wenn man jemand
eine parklücke wegnimmt
da aber ansonsten ist doch die
atmosphäre insgesamt relativ friedlich
zumindest in deutschland für 80
millionen menschen auf so einem engen
gebiet in den fußgängerzonen und und
kaufhäusern und spaßbädern also so kann
sich nicht erklären ich weiß nicht ob es
stimmt der tatort bei dem ja auch die
schweiz jetzt wieder dabei ist endlich
werde in den fonds oft mehr gesprochen
als er neu erschienenen roman der letzte
tatort wird immer gesprochen
ww kommend ein krimi dazu gewissermaßen
zum kulturellen zur kulturellen ikone zu
werden zu sowas ungeheuer wichtigen und
bedeutsamen was doch nur darum geht 90
minuten lang in die spannung aufrecht zu
erhalten also zum einen ist das so eine
funktion die im früher vielleicht mal
wetten dass erfüllt hat dass sich da
eben die familie noch irgendwie vor dem
fernseher ein findet ja dann ist hat
sich das so hochgeschaukelt welches
tatort pa ist das erfolgreichste
mittlerweile haben fast alle zehn
millionen zuschauer
und ich glaube es ist dass das spiegelt
so sehr gut das lebensgefühl von
mittelklasse deutschland wieder also man
ist ein bisschen schwul man ist ein
bisschen patchwork man ist ein bisschen
ausländer
man ist ein bisschen droge die 80
jährige mutter hat einen 11 jährigen
lebensgefährten und so und aber alles
wie gesagt gut verdaulich ja und das ist
so
also ich glaube schon dass es das
lebensgefühl in deutschland ganz gut
widerspiegelt also das ist doch ein bild
der oder zumindest ein einzel oder oder
also jeder ist heute irgendwie vegan
jeder ist tolerant jeder ist irgendwie
will was für die energiewende tun außer
natürlich wenn sie teuer wird jeder will
irgendwie carsharing machen dass die
dies ist dieses diese so sieht die post
grüne phase
ja ich habe es kürzlich gelesen das neue
statussymbol ist nicht mehr das auto
sondern die küche kochinseln ja
verschiedene olivenöle man macht sich
selber für den weg mit dem rennrad zur
arbeit
die pralinen weil die gehen auch ganz
ohne schokolade und das ist dann
irgendwie so so so vegan und die augen
strahlen und die rollen straffen sich
und das lebensgefühl ist ein ganz
anderer nicht glaube das wird schon
alles also dieses dieses dieses smoothie
gefühl das wird glaube ich durch den
tatort perfekt widergespiegelt das
fernsehen bietet er zwei dinge an eben
möglichst nahe an der wirklichkeit oder
scheinbare wirklichkeit beschreibung und
auf der anderen seite reine fantasie sie
sind noch nie gefragt worden ob sie ihn
am tatort -kommissar geben wollen
der mann bietet wir hauptsächlich einen
rollen typ an das ist ein zynischer
anwalt der eine schwangere migrantinnen
aus der wohnung wirft das könnt ihr
privat jederzeit von mir haben aber um
es zu spielen interessiert mich nicht
werden sie auf der anderen seite bei so
einer dieser intellektuellen b seien
damit war jeder intellektuelles abholen
darf man auch nicht immer genügend
mitgemacht haben etwas was wir gemeinsam
haben wir beide schon fest raumschiff
gearbeitet haben sie keine
berührungsängste überhaupt nicht weil
das traumschiff ist ja sozusagen stärker
als jeder vermeintliche qualität
schauspieler sie es gibt ja mehrere
klassen von schauspielern auf beide beim
traumschiff ist also es gibt sozusagen
die die die eigentliche crew die aber
nur drei leute sind was ich auch nicht
kapiert aber der captain der schiffsarzt
und beatrice die hostess dann gibt es
die die richtig guten schauspieler von
von vom deutschen theater in berlin oder
von den kammerspielen oder so wie es
meistens machen weil sie leicht
gehbehinderte mutter haben diese
mitnehmen können auf die reise oder weil
sie häufiger satz auch mir ist gerade
meine ehe um die ohren gestoßen dann
gibt es den attraktiven kleiderständer
die mädels sehen alle aus wie vorher
marlene küsschen und und die jungs haben
alle sixpack die erkennt man daran dass
sie das ganze freizeitangebot mitmachen
den sprung in den dschungel
die stürzen sich ohne drachen vom felsen
die tauchen mit haien 400 meter tief und
so weiter und sind nach ende der reise
entweder schwanger oder haben das
geschlecht gewechselt und dann gibt es
die kritischen schauspieler die
sozusagen am ersten abend mit einem
robert walser bändchen an der reling
sitzen aber nach dem ersten sturm oder
nach dem ersten vollsuff so nach 23
tagen ja die sonne am äquator lockert
einfach jeden und dann werden die auch
relaxt und ich bin dann aber auch muss
ich ehrlich sagen doch beeindruckt mit
welcher ernsthaftigkeit die diese rollen
spielen und was die auch ausholen
aus diesen figuren die ja doch stark
stereotyp sind ja sein müssen
also das ist ich hatte da kein weil ich
fand die reisen fantastisch und ich
finde natürlich wolfgang rademann
erlebnis sozusagen der letzte seiner art
muss man auch für zuschauern erklärt
wolfram an der der letzte saurier der
fernsehunterhaltung langjähriger peter
alexander produzent und eine seiner
lieblings oder meine lieblings angeboten
von ihm ist als er bei der gründung der
deutschen krebsgesellschaft durch
mitchell gab es eine große gala
in köln und er musste also in berlin zum
kölner bahnhof rennen um marika rökk aus
dem zug heraus zu ziehen die zehn
minuten vorher von ihm gesagt bekommen
hatte dass sie nicht geschlossen oder
ist eine heim zu bringen waren
also das ist natürlich eine weit
zurückliegende welt ja oder das
kulenkampff zu frankenfeld gesagt hat er
kriegt die drehbücher extra bezahlt die
sketche und so aber aber das ist das ist
ja das weswegen ich in den beruf
gegangen bin und das sind für mich auch
sozusagen größen die die die
untouchables sind also das was die
konten unerreicht die alten herren sind
wirklich einzelstücke mit ihm ende unter
einer palme sei ja am liebsten das ja
ein buch besprachen und er plötzlich
sagte ich muss jetzt eine runde
schwimmen schwimmen hinter mir her da
können wir weiterreden ja was einem ja
letzten endes lieber ist als ein wohl
gestalter redakteur der seinen
schreibtischstuhl seit jahren nicht mehr
ist absolut unbestechlich im urteil er
sieht jedes jedes movie also es ist und
mir gefällt natürlich auch wenn er
anrufe sage firma ich bin gerade auf
motivsuche in rio und man weiß einfach
gedreht wird sowieso um 15 uhr
entsprechend ist auch in new york das
empire state building und sternstunde
ich war dabei foto rademann durch die
welle der tsunami und vertreten
traumschiff -folge japan wegen der
kirschblüte und wolfgang amann entschied
innerhalb von einer viertelstunde stadt
japan wird jetzt barley gedreht und es
waren aber schon zwei drittel des films
fertig und die musste hinterher ins
studio und musste 27 mal bali sagen wo
im film in japan gesagt wurde
schön wär tree ist hier in bali so sind
die menschen hier in baldige setzen
glück auf zu helfen
also das ist bei rademann
das sensationell genug der lobeshymnen
der einen gemeinsamen freund ich hatte
mal einen button ich habe ihn leider
verloren
da stand drauf theater ist leben film
ist kunst fernsehen ist möblierung
würden sie dieser einteilung der drei
staaten zustimmen nicht mehr
das ist alles die die die grenzen sind
total aufgehoben in meiner erfahrung
es war für mich so eine so ein
schockerlebnis dass ich mit mit fast
pubertärem enthusiasmus vor paar jahren
noch mal in der kantine von
verschiedenen theatern saß und aus der
steinzeit erzählte mit gert voss und
jutta lampe und bruno ganz und die
protagonisten dieser häuser hat nur
einen wunsch
dianes sie wollten tatort kommissar
werden die fernsehleute wollen immer zum
theater theater leute wollen immer zum
fernseher
ja ja ja und weil beide sind eigentlich
schlecht beraten weil die finden sind
zwar unterschiedliche berufe ist zieht
sie nicht ans theater zurück dass das
ist komplett ausgeträumt ja das ist wir
haben so über das das thema
berührungsängste gesprochen
es gibt ja auch bei einem selbst
erklärten zyniker wie ihn gibt es ja
ganz klare grenzen
sie haben mal einen preis ich weiß mehr
welcher preis das war abgelehnt weil sie
mit der moral des präsentators nicht
einverstanden waren gesagt haben von dem
was ich mir keinen preis überreichen
das war die goldene feder des bauer
verlags ein preis der in etwa
anzusiedeln ist der größenordnung des
des büchner preises und das war 1 1 ein
massaker in erfurt ein schüler lief amok
und am abend reiste kollege kerner nach
erfurt um dort mit schüler vor die
kamera zu ziehen
nach dem motto deutschland spricht
darüber und da gibt's für mich gar kein
grund außer blanken tourismus und dass
das war mir dann zeitlich zu dicht und
dann habe ich das gesagt mach ich nicht
kommen mithin nur ist da der unterschied
vom war juristisch und zynismus zum
reinen verbalen zynismus den sie ja
der unterschied ist dass das das ja gar
nicht als zynismus empfunden wird
sondern als als bereitschaft extrem
seriös journalistisch zu haben in einem
ganz heissen umfeld was übrigens für 80
prozent der talkshows guckt ja es werden
leute ran geholt und das kapieren auch
übrigens viele prominente nicht sie
werden immer sozusagen führt für das
drama für das man sie kennt eingeladen
auch wenn es heißt wir reden über werden
pflanzen wichtiger kommt immer dann die
frage wieder war das damals als sie
geschossen haben frau van bergen
dann kann man die uhr danach stellen ja
und und da das war einfach und ich finde
da da da da müsste auch das zdf sich mal
fragen ob es noch so was wie ein ethos
gibt wenn man nun wirklich am tag von
ich weiß nicht wie viele schüler da
erschossen wurden
also da deutschland war gelähmt von
diesem ereignis wenn man sagt da gehen
wir nun mit unserer
bunten kessel wäsche show dahin
da gibt es um gar keinen grund es sei
denn man wird alle regeln über bord ja
aber dann interpretiert man das
grundgesetz schon sehr sehr elastisch
also kann man die die moral grenze des
das geht nun wirklich nicht kann man das
definieren oder wenn man sie definiert
geht es um personen geht es um
situationen wo muss man die linie 10
also ich eigentlich heißt die regel ab
einem nettoeinkommen von 5000 euro ist
jeder strafbar ja und ich glaube schon
dass man das überprüfen könnte wir haben
immer nur auf leute eingedroschen die
freiwillig den kopf gehängt haben
und wir haben sie vergessen steuern zu
zahlen oder sie standen mit der falschen
unterwäsche auf dem falschen balkon ja
aber wir haben nie unter dem vorwurf wir
nehmen
schicksale besonders ernst ja punkt der
dümmlichkeit wenn schauspieler mit den
figuren die sie gerade gespielt haben in
der anschließenden talk show nach dem
film sitzen ja dass das haben wir
niemals gemacht also denn niemals
sozusagen in wir haben uns niemals an an
opfer dran gehängt oder leute mit mit
nun fürchterlichen schicksalen für zehn
minuten eingeladen und hinterher wenn
sie glück haben zeigte noch der
feuerwehrmann wie es wieder aus dem
studio aus finden dass das ist für mich
wir haben sozusagen in der kunstwelt
bewegt ja könnten sie das motto lieber
ehrlich verlogen als verlogen ehrlich
unterschreiben dass das ist ehrlich
gesagt mir zu
da müsste ich erst drüber darüber nach
den also ich finde
man sollte sich mit moralischen
bewertungen sehr zurückhaltend ja und
dass das mit mit kerner damals war
sondern auch das war für mich ganz klar
dass ich da nicht hin gewandelt
weil ich sie ganz klar ist ich
ausschlachtung dieses ereignis war in
zusammenarbeit mit der bild zeitung ja
das ist einfach alles vollkommen
offensichtlich gewesen
das kann ja jeder halten wie er will ja
nur ich muss mich da nicht angucken
gerade da müsste ich jetzt drei minuten
darüber nachdenken in ihren sendungen
haben sie ja solche sachen gemacht alle
regeln des fernsehens über bord geworfen
und dann auch mal hätten sie auch noch
unterbrochen gesagt mehr machen drei
minuten muss ich jetzt nachdenken
hätte ich gemacht ja ja das war so das
das anti- fahren sie traditionellste
furchtbares wort gemacht haben ich hätte
mich jetzt kommt meine sendung ist die
wahl gehen französisch ja aber das war
gar nicht weit das war ja sozusagen klar
in diesem format kann das passieren
das anti fernseh mäßigte war doch
eindeutig während verstehen sie spaß wo
ich zum beispiel 300 meter innerhalb von
ludwigsburg mit dem hubschrauber
geflogen bin um pommes frites zu holen
live oder eine minute lang metronom habe
laufen lassen um den zuschauer vor augen
zu führen was ne minute am samstagabend
im deutschen fernsehen kostet oder
gesagt habe richard wagner der große
komponist starb in venedig der stadt der
gondeln und dann wurde hinten eine
gondel aus dem berner oberland durch
getragen
ja und das löst er natürlich ja nicht
nur komplettes unverständnis aus sondern
auch echte aggression bei den zuschauern
mir gegenüber aber ich habe das immer
sport tief gesehen ja wie viele
redakteure was nun anschließenden die
klinik eingeliefert werden keiner der
hauptverantwortliche
war eh schon ab 11 uhr beim riesling
also da war es kein kein grund und die
redakteurin damals muss man sagen hat es
immer unterstützt ich hatte mit den
rektoren euch niemals schwierigkeiten
weil die redakteure sozusagen
immerhin das gefühl auch hatten die
wussten ja was wir sonst machen mussten
ja wenn sie alle zwei minuten den
teleporter anhalten müssen weil der
moderator bei kunden an meine damen und
herren stolpert dann genießt es hier als
wenn zumindest mal irgendeiner sagte wir
machen diesmal eine live hinrichtung
ja wir entscheiden aber erst in der
sendung bei wem der dicke die wussten ja
auch dass es vielleicht irgendwann vom
sender fliegt aber es war natürlich
interessanter und spannender als das
meiste was es sonst machen mussten
schönes nrw oder wie die sendung alle
heißen
aber wenn man so viele sendungen macht
auf fünf mal die woche geriet man da
nicht irgendwann auch so in den strudel
dass man dann auch sagt ich freue mich
ganz besonders haben sie uns zu begrüßen
obwohl man sich ja nicht bei jedem gast
ganz besonders freuen kann oder so doch
aber das ist ja das ist ja der geheimen
code mit dem zuschauer das machen die
amerikaner noch immer harmloser wenn ich
sage mein nächster gast ist eine unserer
vielseitigste schauspielerin eine
unserer wunderbaren künstlerin die jetzt
auch noch schreibt herzlich willkommen
frau xy
dann setze ich darauf dass der zuschauer
kapiert wie es gemeint ist das muss man
aber ganz klar sagen wird immer weniger
kapiert es wird eins zu eins so genommen
ja und man kann es vielleicht so sagen
ich habe so eine kategorie entdeckt von
schriftstellern in deutschland gibt es
das sogenannte tote mutter autor ja also
das heißt wir fällt eigentlich sein ich
kann auch nicht schreiben aber ich
schreibe mal über die letzten jahre
meiner mutter als mutti starb ja finde
ich geht nicht dass das ist die
kategorie ich kann ich schreibe meine
schwester kann ich meine sondern
kinderbuch der zuschauer findet ist aber
doch zum großen teil ergriffen dass da
einer konfusion engen kontakt hat und
das schicksal der mutter war ja auch so
ergreifend denn wann stirbt ja schon mal
eine mutter das kommt ja auch ein nie
vor
kaum eine mutter stirbt sieht man
wirklich der zuschauer merkt nicht er
kommt jetzt um sein buch zu promoten
sondern wird echt ergriffen oder dabei
dass da das dass die leute kommen um das
buch zu promoten das ist akzeptiert das
ist von den zuschauern akzeptiert dass
der nichts anderes kann das sozusagen
die tote mutter schriftstellers
ausschlachten muss sonst hätte er gar
nichts zu schreiben
das wird nicht wahrgenommen sondern wenn
sie sagen toll dieses einem t shirt
erstaunlich was so kleine bangladesch
finger ich dann alles nehmen können sagt
das publikum zynisch ja wenn sie aber
die rechnung der mutti noch am
sterbebett abschreiben es immer wieder
sich einfühlen kann und meine tante
uschi war es ja ähnlich ja also das sind
vielleicht sehr sehr sehr schwer
nachvollziehbare unterscheidungen aber
ich finde das ergebnis eindeutig dass es
eben meine show nicht mehr gibt also die
leute wollen da betrogen werden gespielt
werden ja wie man wirklich der zuschauer
will das auch so haben und er mache ich
auch nicht wenn man die regeln verletzt
hat der zuschauer ist daraufhin
abgerichtet meiner meinung nach
und das halte ich sogar für
systemrelevant wenn sie sozusagen sagen
würden moment mal was kriegt er
eigentlich geboten ist das wirklich so
da kann man das auch anders sehen
dann kommen sie vielleicht auf die idee
warum soll ich ein für 2000 euro
im krankenhaus arbeiten eigentlich ist
es doch mindestens 10.000 euro wert ja
und dann könnte es doch zu leichten
turbulenzen im öffentlichen nahverkehr
kommen und deswegen glaube ich dass so
eine sonne normierung von reaktionen was
man zu empfinden hat ja geboten haben
einen zu einem anderen menschen zu
machen
das erleben von geboten ja
bei todesfällen zum beispiel als mein
vater starb erwartet für diese idee er
war 90 und für sich mal ein geheimnis
verraten ich habe mit ihm gesprochen
also noch gelebt hat ja so hart so oder
viele unserer schauspielerinnen legen
sich noch mal zwei nächte ins bett mit
der toten mutter um abschied zu nehmen
sagt das muss ich nicht weil ich lade
mir meine modell wird als er noch gelebt
hat so das wird alles als zynisch
denunziert aber es ist ja ein racer
geblieben seid ihr jetzt ein
afrikanischer uhr stammen oder seid ihr
eigentlich zehn jahren oder was was soll
jetzt das dass man noch mit oder mutter
wieder ins bett liegen muss sich und das
ist aber in gewisser weise gibt es da
eine norm die reaktionen und emotionen
vorgibt abrufbar
also ich weiß jetzt wurde ist tot bücher
lesen sie nicht welche bücher lesen sie
quer durch also zurzeit lese ich mit mit
wirklichem enthusiasmus die tagebücher
der brüder concours muss auch sagen
gehört hat uns der verleger hat den
nobelpreis verdient zusammen mit andrea
übersetzerinnen 1 1 dass er diese 1000
seiten werk wo jeder zdf-redakteur sagen
würde du concours das ist doch sind es
nicht türken versteht dass unsere
zuschauer usw
es wird einfach gemacht und es gibt ein
rieseninteresse und alle die sagen
unsere zeit ist so schlecht es ist so
negative keine zeitungen gelesen die
jugend ist allerdings die sollen diese
tagebücher lesen da steht fest asche und
drehen besser formuliert und 150 jahre
zurück also für mich ist das rp diese
weise unglaubliches was da geschrieben
wird aber ich lese auch ich kaufe mir
auch für für für zugfahrten irgendwie so
berlin-mitte literatur literatur sind
frauen anfang 30
die diesen roman schreiben mit drei
figuren meistens patchwork und der der
plot ist meistens 10 uhr haare färben 14
uhr abtreibungen 18 uhr lecker essen und
dann auf 120 seiten gestreckt groß
gedruckt wird aber er lebt von
kurzfristigen hype auf spiegel online
das lese ich dann so mal schnell im zug
nach wie wir seiten schmeißen sind buch
reckless ihnen nicht gefällt so ein buch
lässt sich durch weiter da freue ich
mich über jedes wo sie ja bei mir ein
hack über jeder stelle im buch was mich
daran langweilt oder so 20 30 seiten und
dann erwartung schoss weg wir fangen
jetzt nicht danach welche bücher der
sind viel essig muss bücher wegwerfen
weil ich nur ein relativ kleines regal
habe und es ist auch ehrlich gesagt ab
einem gewissen alter trägt auch vieles
nicht mehr
ja also die ist es dampft sich ein was
was über längeren zeitraum hin bestand
hat fangen wir mal nach den nach den
anderen kunstformen sie sind ja wenn ich
zu meiner großen überraschung
festgestellt habe
diplomierter kirchenmusikers das war
hielt cc prüfung zu prüfung bitte erzähl
prüfung sind eigentlich der spread
housewives vorwiegend aus oberschwaben
jetzt die sich mit unfassbar
komplizierten max reger oder oder buck
von der orgel abquälen die üben wie die
irren die mit somit zur eleganteren
gesundheitsschuhen die pedale hinkriegen
wollen das wirklich die hornhaut von den
von den zehennägeln staubt vom ehrgeiz
getriebene menschen wie ich auch die
eben sich in harmonielehre einarbeiten
werke die es nicht schaffen und dann so
ein für einen laien ganz guten einblick
in die welt der musik regen und die c
prüfung wird von von wirklich begabten
benutzt um sich auf die aufnahmeprüfung
an der musikhochschule vorzubereiten was
man da erkennt dass die zur
aufnahmeprüfung schon dinge spielen die
die anderen am schluss nicht schaffen ja
sie haben durch die prüfung das recht
gottesdienste an der orbit zu begleiten
nehme ich mir aber ich habe zehn jahre
lang gemacht jeden sonntag drei
gottesdienste 2 in kirchen und ein im
gemeindehaus in den kindergottesdienst
da können sie da nicht ihre prominenz
nutzen um an die wirklich tollen orten
die man nie zu spielen krieg mal anzug
und doch aber ist jetzt das wird sie
überraschen
respekt der domorganist hat mir
angeboten ja ich will dauernd an im
osten wo diese originale sind die
barocken usw aber nichts grauenhaftes
als wirklich so zeit leiten derzeit
redakteure die dann noch im alter horn
lernen oder so oder helmut schmidt auf
dem flügel von justus frantz man ist
entweder waren bäume oder spielt zu
hause aber zu hause spielen zu hause
spiele ich ja mit der familie hausmusik
zum teil auch ja das ist super es klingt
in passagen nach stockhausen auch wenn
es eigentlich boccherini ist aber dass
das ist eine disziplin und dass es
erstaunlich daran dass ich doch gar alle
reinfinden
darf ich da wir uns schon im schluss der
sendung nähern einen kleinen test mit
ihnen bitte man hat mir gesagt es ist
keiner ist so schlagfertig und sofort
mit einer mit einer pointe bereit wie
harald schmidt den rufen sie selber
eingebrockt
wir hatten doch in der schweiz gerade
diese ein masseneinwanderung initiative
mit 50,3 prozent angenommen wurde
nehmen wir an wir werden hier nicht am
sonntagmorgen sondern in der late night
show welche pointer macht man über die
schweizer in diesem zusammenhang ehrlich
gesagt habe ich alle schweiz ich bin ein
riesen fan der schweiz und ich würde
mich niemals zu innenpolitischen
vorgängen in einem land äußert sich zu
gast bin
das finde ich auch hier lächerlich wenn
das andere
in deutschland auch lächerlich wenn sich
in länder in deutschland dazu äußern
ja aber wird alles was ich über schweiz
gemacht haben lief immer über das was in
deutschland als schweizer mundart durch
flügel das klischee das volk rieche ja
und wo du einfach sagt wo ein satz den
ich von einem schweizer gehört habe
nicht zu groß gewachsen aber war lange
chef von sat 1 mit dem ich im taxi durch
berlin führen sagte haye vorn lief man
sich kaufen wir jetzt das penthouse ja
also das sind das genügt für deutschland
mit mit mit dieser in der schweiz wird
ist mir nicht trauen aber der wegen in
zürichs entgeht aber die diese 50 50
abstimmungen
das ist okay das ist eine angelegenheit
der schweiz und wir wissen ja solche
abstimmungsergebnisse sind wichtig um
die die leistungsträger und system
stabilisatoren bei laune zu halten aber
längst wird natürlich auf einer zweiten
ebene gesagt eu internationale freunde
nicht nervös werden wir werden jetzt
dieses tolle abstimmungsergebnis dafür
wahnsinnig ernst nehmen
mit unseren europäischen und singapur
inzwischen und indonesischen freunden in
abstimmung bringen
[Musik]
wer aus östlichen gebieten an den
zürichsee zu uns gezogen ist und hier
die kindergartenbeiträge pünktlich zahlt
der ist ja auch nicht gemeint meinungen
auch politische können sich ändern ich
hoffe die harald schmidt show meinung
nie mehr gesehen hat sich auch noch mal
ändern mich jetzt freuen herzlichen dank
dass sie heute bei unseren vielen dank
für die einladung
[Musik]